[MUSIC PLAYING]
LIZ FONG-JONES: Welcome
to episode seven
of our series on SRE and DevOps.
I'm Liz Fong-Jones, a site
reliability engineer at Google,
where I teach Google Cloud
customers how to build
and operate reliable services.
SETH VARGO: [YAWNS]
LIZ FONG-JONES: Where
have you been, Seth?
SETH VARGO: I'm Seth,
I'm a developer advocate.
[YAWNS] I'm sorry I'm late.
I was up all night
dealing with these alerts
from these systems.
It was just a
really hectic night.
LIZ FONG-JONES: Ugh, that's
the worst when that happens.
And what experience
were your users having?
Were they happy, or were
they impacted by the alerts?
SETH VARGO: [YAWNS]
Honestly, that
was the most frustrating part.
I get paged about this
single server that
had slow or low disk space
or low network bandwidth,
but only a small percentage
of queries were affected.
And by the time I got there,
the load balancer had already
routed traffic away, so there
was nothing for me to do.
LIZ FONG-JONES: Sounds like
you have too many alerts,
and they're not doing you
any good at actually catching
problems affecting real users.
And that leaves you
really, really tired
when something does
actually break.
So let's see how we can maybe
reduce some of that noise.
SETH VARGO: So my partner
and I would greatly
appreciate getting to
sleep through the night
unless things are
actually on fire.
But I'm worried, too,
because I've heard rumors
that the rest of
my team is actually
ignoring alerts and putting
their phones in Do Not Disturb
mode because none of the
alerts are actionable,
or very few of them
are actionable.
And I'm worried
that that's going
to put our business at risk
in the event of a real outage.
LIZ FONG-JONES: Yeah, so you
have service level indicators
and service level objectives.
Remember last time?
SETH VARGO: Yeah, we do.
We have an automated system that
verifies that you can log in,
you can add things to
your shopping cart,
and you can check out.
And our service
level indicator is
defined based on whether
that probe, that process,
succeeds without error and
whether it completes quickly
enough in our time frame.
And then our service
level objective, or SLO,
is that integrated over,
say, the past 30 days.
And the SLI must be satisfied
for 99.9%, or three nines,
of all of the probes.
LIZ FONG-JONES: Great, so you're
measuring your performance
and what users are experiencing.
But are you using that to alert?
SETH VARGO: Wait, you want
me to add more alerts?
I want to sleep more.
LIZ FONG-JONES:
Well, yes, but we'll
eventually wind up turning
off the redundant alerts that
are measuring potential
causes of problems
rather than
corresponding necessarily
to actual unhappy users.
So remember, what we're trying
to do is make our users happy.
So by using the SLO measurements
to decide whether our users are
experiencing actual
symptoms of pain,
then we can use
that to guide us,
and everything
else is extraneous.
SETH VARGO: OK,
that makes sense.
LIZ FONG-JONES: So
let's take an example.
You said you wanted to
have your SLI satisfied
99.9% over 30 days.
So that means that
you have an error
budget of 43 minutes per
30 days of 100% outage,
or potentially longer if you
had a partial brownout, right?
SETH VARGO: Right, that
math sounds familiar.
LIZ FONG-JONES:
OK, so you'd want
to find out and be
able to intervene
to put the system back
to correctness relatively
quickly if you are expending
error budget far more
quickly than the error
budget indicates.
For instance, you'd
clearly have a problem
if you spent a quarter
of your error budget
for the whole month
within two hours,
either by being hard
down for 10 minutes
or by having a partial
brownout of 10% of your probes
for those two hours.
SETH VARGO: Well, I see.
And if that pattern continued
for the next few hours, or even
minutes, I could
potentially wind up
spending my entire error budget
for the quarter or the year.
LIZ FONG-JONES: Exactly.
But we can't put it
on a hair trigger
or else it will
falsely alert us when
we have a blip for two
minutes, rather than something
that winds up repeating itself
within the next two hours.
So we can have some
situations where
a partial brownout
wouldn't necessarily
endanger our error budget.
SETH VARGO: Yeah, I've
had enough noisy pages
to want to avoid that
happening ever again.
But I think I can spot a
small hole in your logic.
Like, what if I deployed
some code that introduced,
say, a small
performance regression?
Something maybe half of
a percent of my probes
will constantly fail.
I'd never catch it by
looking for too many failures
in a window of hours.
That would be indistinguishable
from other noise in the system.
LIZ FONG-JONES: Yes,
you're exactly correct.
So we also need
a slow burn alert
to track down over the past week
if we're exceeding our error
budget at an acceptable rate.
For instance, we could check
whether more than 0.15%
of queries were failing when
we're only allowed 0.1%.
And we could raise a
lower priority ticket
that someone could look
at during business hours
once we are
sufficiently confident.
SETH VARGO: So as
I understand it,
we need both fast burn
and slow burn alerts
to provide a feedback
loop on our SLO
and make sure that we're
fixing real issues that
are affecting real users.
LIZ FONG-JONES: Exactly.
And Stackdriver SLO
from Google Cloud
can help you by automatically
determining and showing to you
what your error budget is,
how much of it you spend,
and alerting you
when it's in danger.
And once you've set up
these SLO-based alerts,
you can turn off all
of the noisy alerts
because you're
only getting alerts
about the high importance
problems that are actually
causing user impact.
SETH VARGO: OK, but
how do I actually find
the problems in my
system so that I
feel confident turning off
the no longer needed alerts?
I'm worried that I'm
going to lose data or be
unable to fix issues now.
LIZ FONG-JONES: That sounds
like an excellent subject for us
to discuss on the next
episode about observability
of distributed systems.
Thanks to everyone for watching,
and we'll catch you next time.
Please remember to like
and subscribe below.
[MUSIC PLAYING]